[Music]
you know we don't expect to see a riot
when we go outside
but the riot in some sense is the
default condition
and we're so protected that we're so
protected as as modern westerners let's
say
that we don't even know what the walls
guard us from
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations
with fascinating people we're delighted
to say that our guest today is a very
special man it is of course
jordan b peterson author psychologist
and an inspiration to a lot of people
he's just written a book called
uh beyond order 12 more rules for life
here it is
thank you for the advanced copy jordan
and thank you for coming on the show
thank you guys for the invitation i'm
very much looking forward to it
it's very kind of you too except let's
get straight into the book first of all
one of the themes that you've explored
most of all in your last two books is of
course order and chaos and that tension
that exists i think
within societies but also within
individuals between
the safety of boredom of order and the
danger and simultaneously excitement of
chaos
what is a healthy balance and how does
one get there at an individual level but
also the level of society what does that
look like
well i think you're actually calibrated
to detect that healthy balance
with with with the deepest of emotional
and cognitive instincts
and and i mean instinct i think it's
biologically based
so you you have two problems at least
two problems as a
living organism in an environment that's
too complex you have to
maintain security but you also have to
stay updated as
things around you change so you want
things to be stable because otherwise
it's too unpredictable and dangerous but
things can't be stable completely
because you don't know everything
so you're stuck with the limitations of
your knowledge so then the question is
well
how can you survive when you don't know
enough
and when the consequence of not knowing
enough is danger
and the answer to that is you you
establish stability but you explore
and so there you you you have the
security that you need but you update
that security and keep it
living and the instinct that governs
that as far as i can tell
is the sense of engaged meaning
and why wouldn't there be an instinct
for that it it's so crucial to your
survival
it's it's it's it it's as crucial as
anything else you obviously have to eat
and you have to
drink you have to regulate your
temperature there's these fundamental
biological necessities but
you have to you you have to master the
environment in order to do all of that
and then that leads you into the problem
of security and exploration and
even if you look at it neurobiologically
that
the system for example that governs
exploration
is unbelievably archaic ancient from an
evolutionary perspective
it's half the hypothalamus roughly
speaking the hypothalamus is a
very old brain area sits on top of the
spinal cord essentially it's
in some sense it's the master control
system for motivation
it governs hunger and thirst and
defensive aggression
and um temperature regulation these
these
and and sexual arousal these very very
fundamental attributes
but half of it is devoted to exploration
and
in that system there's a neurochemical
system that emerges out of it
which runs on a neurochemical called
dopamine and all of the drugs that
people like to abuse
like cocaine for example activates the
dopamine system that's why people like
it
and so you can tell when you're in the
right place doing the right thing
because you're actively engaged
and that is a signal that the balance
between stability and
incoming information is optimized for
you
jordan don't you think one of the
problems that we've got in our society
at the moment
is we tend to celebrate chaos we tend to
celebrate
because i associate creativity with
chaos but order is seen as dole
stayed boring but order is what is
needed to get things done and if you
look at what is happening now within
our institutions our systems it seems
that order is unraveling
well look the critique of order which is
its stultification tendency right it's
look
you zero out everything that's
predictable
right it becomes boring it becomes so
boring you don't even notice it
so for example if if you're lecturing to
people in any given room and you ask
them to close their eyes and then you
ask them to
imagine that the color of the wall on
the right of them
most people can't remember because who
cares
as long as the wall is standing it
doesn't matter what color it is
and right now you and i the three of us
are talking and
we're attending to the words we're not
attending to anything
around us you're not attending to the
fact that the floor beneath you is
stable but it's stable because you can
rely on the engineers and
the engineers are encapsulated within a
legal system that has certain building
standards and
the reason that that floor is stable is
because you live in this unbelievably
developed country where you can take
such things for granted and
you can't help but be bored by that in
fact if you weren't you'd be attending
to everything at once and
well that would be absolutely
overwhelming
and again in our society too it's very
very hard
not to take things for granted right
and i've tried to train myself to do
that um partly by reading
a vast amount i would say about what
happens in societies when they become
too chaotic
you know we don't expect to see a riot
when we go outside
but the riot in some sense is the
default condition
and we're so protected that we're so
protected as as modern westerners let's
say
that we don't even know what the walls
guard us from
and that's also a very typical narrative
idea so
in the lord of the rings for example the
hobbits are protected by these
warriors the striders who patrol the
borders constantly they're descendants
of old kings
aragorn is the foremost among them and
they protect the hobbits from all the
darkness and unknown
that's outside the kingdom but the
hobbits don't even know and that's us
we're protected from things we don't
understand at all by things we don't
understand at all and
we'll tear down the walls because we
don't know what's behind them
but you know it it's not an easy problem
to solve
gratitude solves it to some degree
historical knowledge solves it
a historical knowledge was to solve it
but wouldn't you also say that
exposure to other cultures and society
solves it
so for me my mother's from venezuela
i've seen what happens when society
unravels
i've seen what happens when bad ideas
are allowed to run rampant
and that has very much inoculated me
it's inoculated constantine
against this type of thinking but
wouldn't you agree that
in a way we're privileged to use that
word because most people in the uk or
the u.s or canada
they haven't been exposed to what
happens when society unravels
well that that's very fortunate
obviously but it does have the
the effect that we've been discussing
which is that people take things for
granted
um and they celebrate chaos well i want
freedom it's like no you don't
you want a tiny bit of freedom meted out
in very calibrated doses on one
dimension now and then
and you want everything else to be as
stable as possible and some people can
tolerate more chaos than others
you know if you're extremely open in
your personality that's the creativity
dimension
and you're highly intelligent and you're
conscientious and you're emotionally
stable
so you don't suffer from negative
emotion in into excess amount
you can handle more chaos than someone
who doesn't have those attributes but
still most of the time well look what do
you want when you sleep
silence and predictability that's not
chaos that's that's a rarity right just
think about
how difficult it is to set up a
situation where you can reliably have
temperature regulated silence 100
of the time at night for your whole life
that's such a luxury and of course
unless you
lose it for some reason you become you
develop insomnia
or or you're in an unfortunate situation
where you don't have that peace anymore
you won't even notice that that's a
privilege
it's an ins it's an unbelievable
privilege and it's so unlikely and
and that's partly i guess why my books
concentrate to a large degree on
gratitude it's like
so many things are going right
well you forget about them you know
that's that and and you have to be
reminded it's a fundamental purpose of
education is to remind you
what you have to be grateful about and i
i think that's the proper basis of
patriotism
rather than pride right you could have
pride in your country it's like yeah
well that kind of rubs off on you you
know it's like rah-rah
england or canada and then you know that
makes me part of
what i'm shaking my fist in favor of but
gratitude is a different thing it's like
well thank god
thank god that i don't have to think
about the damn floor
and you know you go to third world
countries badly run countries where
the building standards are non-existent
or
or the entire construction company uh
infrastructure is corrupt
well then the earth shakes a little bit
and you have to worry about the dam
floor so
jordan you you use the word education i
think in the context of this
conversation this is something that's
that i've been thinking about because
one of the shocking things to me
as someone who was born in the soviet
union i remember talking to my
grandmother still alive she's going to
be 95 this year
she lived through the german occupation
of ukraine and i remember talking to her
about her childhood and she said the
thing that me and my girlfriends were
discussing when i was 15
was will we ever eat bread again
will we ever eat bread again and that
has always stayed with me and that's why
for me gratitude for everything we have
here in the west
has never been difficult but i wonder is
there a way we can
transcend the fact that i had to hear
that from my own grandmother
how do we educate other people about
what happens in this sort of society
what happens when you let identitarian
ideologies take over these large sways
of
of europe and asia and come into
conflict what happens when
when this sort of way of thinking takes
over
because you've been very interested in
the soviet union you've educated
yourself into it but i don't see that
happening particularly
with young people in the west these days
no
it was it was shocking to me that so i
lectured mostly to students about the
soviet union
especially under stalin but certainly
also under lenin
um about the horrors of the soviet union
i lectured about that in my personality
class in
in the second year psychology course
and that was a valid enterprise because
totalitarianism is a personality
attribute
in some sense as well as a social system
but it was often the first
any of the students had heard of any of
that you know which is
to me was just absolutely well it's so
outrageous that it's virtually
unbelievable
especially when you think that we
we put the entire planet at risk for 50
years
at risk of total annihilation because of
what happened in the soviet union
and we're barely out of that if we're
out of it at all i mean the russians and
the americans still rattle sabers at
each other
i think the possibility of anything
other than an
accidental nuclear exchange has
decreased immensely since the mid 80s
let's say
but how is it that we could be so
blind that we would
forget to note to notify our young
people that
we fought like the second world war
really didn't end until 1989.
that isn't how the history books look at
it yet but that's the case and
it's just stunning that that none of
that is common knowledge
you know there's a little bit more
historical knowledge disseminated
about what happened in nazi germany but
the deafening silence
on with regards to maoist china which is
still an immense threat
not least in the form of north korea and
the soviet union it's
it's it's so remarkable that it's a kind
of
miracle so but it is the responsibility
of the education system as far as i can
tell where else are you going to
i mean it's the social responsibility of
the education system
in terms of individuals well you know
now everyone has access to
all the communication technology they
could possibly want
and so if you have a particular interest
in making something known
you can just do it and so hopefully
people will do that you guys are
obviously doing that with your
youtube channel and your podcast
agreed i i was going to ask you actually
just
as a personal thing really what made you
interested in the soviet union why was
how were you drawn to to reading about
it and educating yourself about it first
of all
it's really hard to tell you know i
i think well curiosity just general
curiosity is one
driver so um
i'm curious about virtually everything
and
i also have a proclivity towards
depression
and i think that maybe that makes
negative things hit me harder
in general well russian history will
help you very well without
literature or anything else yeah so i
think that
it's possible that i was sort of wired
to take these things more seriously
because they hit me harder
you know like i noticed in graduate
school for example that
um like i i was obsessed with the
with with the shortness of life that was
an idea that was in my head constantly
that it was it was not appropriate to
waste time because
time was fleeting and short and i
thought that pretty much every morning i
woke up for years
when i was writing my first book and
that was definitely a motivating
force to write that book which i really
did on spec over about a 15-year period
but i but i had all sorts of friends in
graduate school and they were very smart
people and
um admirable people as far as i was
concerned hard-working and
and curious and good research scientists
mcgill had an excellent clinical program
and i had an
absolute riot it was such fun going to
graduate school there
but my friends weren't consumed by
darkness the same way i was even though
they were clinically interested
for i was obsessed with it and
specifically
with the issue of mo individual
motivation for
atrocity i didn't i was interested in
the sociological elements of nazi
germany and the soviet union
and mao's china interested in the
political elements and i my first degree
was actually in political science but
i soon found that i was much more
oriented towards dostoyevsky let's say
than tolstoy
i like toll story but tosto is basically
a sociologist right he writes about
these
wide swaths of of of of sociological
occurrences sort of at the level of
society
but i like dostoevsky because he got
inside people's heads
and that's what i was really interested
in it was like it wasn't
how the concentrations camps were set up
politically or even what ideology
motivated them but
what was the guard thinking when he
pushed people to the right rather than
the left what what was in his head
as a person what would and as if i was
there
and it was always personal to me and not
even so much on the victim's side
i always thought of it on the
perpetrator side because it was such a
mystery to me how could you be like that
and well that was very illuminating to
me
i mean it transformed my personality
entirely i would say
studying that um partly because i
realized that
you don't have to be that different than
you are and that's a very
that makes you different than you think
and in some ways
it's you take yourself a lot more
seriously when you understand that
right as soon as you understand that
you're a loose cannon
in in a really fundamental sense you
start being more careful
and so that was really helpful to me and
i think i became much more careful
perhaps careful with more careful with
what i said for sure
i you know as much as i was able
and jordan do you think part of the
problem with today's society
is that we don't acknowledge that we
have this in us
we like to pretend on social media and
so it's whatever it may be that we're
this
you know really moral woke good people
without any shadow but the reality is is
that we are all dark we're all complex
we all have
shadow within us and the propensity to
commit
both beautiful acts but also acts which
could easily be described as evil
well i i think that
it's better to identify the enemy within
than the enemy without
that doesn't mean that you should never
identify the enemy without
right sometimes your group matters and
the enemy is the enemy is at your gates
and you have to take action but
in in peaceful circumstances let's say
well then i think it's an individual
matter and so this is one of the things
that's made me
ashamed of the universities in large
part too i would say because
there's such an activist culture in the
university it's like it's almost like a
moral rite of passage
you become adolescent and one late
adolescent on your
the steps into adulthood and you're
encouraged tacitly and
explicitly by the university culture to
protest to
to to find the perpetrators to alter the
system it's like
no i don't think that's a good idea
i i think there's something deeply wrong
about that
in all sorts of ways first of all you
know you don't know anything
it's true you just don't know what it is
and look we
the thing that we should make clear here
jordan is when we
laugh at that we're laughing at
ourselves from
20 30 40 50 years ago whenever it was
for each of us
we know that we can laugh at the idea
that students don't know anything
because we were one student
who didn't know anything absolutely well
and it's not like i don't take
undergraduate
seriously i love university teaching
and i took the undergraduate seriously i
never thought of them as a
burden to my research career say i love
teaching and my
experience with undergraduates was you
pretty much got back from them what you
gave so if you were
intent on teaching they responded
unbelievably positively
and and so um it's not like i have
contempt for undergraduates
quite the contrary and one
one of the things i really i taught at
harvard for a while and that was quite
an experience
the university was exceptionally well
run at that time
um hopefully that's still the case um
the the undergraduates were at the top
of the power hierarchy and
they were treated and you could be
cynical about it you know i used to joke
that harvard treated its undergraduates
like
baby 40 year old millionaires
and they did and and part of that was
pure economic calculation right because
harvard has a huge endowment and it it
has that endowment because it's so good
at treating its undergraduates properly
and selecting them as well so it's a
great deal for harvard especially if
you're thinking over decades
but that's the right way to treat
undergraduates it's not as
18 year olds who knew nothing but as
future
incredibly competent adults and
but that still having said all that
when you're 18 you haven't had a child
you it's unlikely that you've engaged in
the kind of long-term intimate
relationship that requires
adult level compromise over let's say
the years you haven't worked
or if you have minimally and often not
at all you certainly haven't started a
business
you you haven't written anything you
haven't created anything
with exceptions so it's not time
to be thinking you know how to
reconstruct the world
and why we think that's okay is just
beyond me
it's like it's not okay i figured that
out when i was about 17
16 17. i worked for a socialist party
when i was a kid
and i had a career there if i wanted it
it was quite obvious
um but i woke up one day partly up under
the influence of this roommate of mine
who's still a really good friend of mine
and he
he'd been kicked around a lot he was
from a really poor background he was a
tough guy he worked on oil rigs and lead
smelters and
he banged around a lot and he was a
little older when he went back to
university and
he was a cynical compassionate
optimist and he ended up working with
like the worst delinquents in canada and
he
could really do that well because he was
a tough guy and
he told me one day um
you just don't know anything like you
have this theory which was a socialist
theory
but it was certainly wasn't mine
although i knew it and i could say it
and i could argue for it
and win the arguments for that matter
said that doesn't explain the world
and i'd already kind of figured that out
i noticed that
i worked on this board board of
governors for this little college i went
to
and all the people on the board of
governors had been appointed by the
government and the government was
conservative
and so they were all small businessmen
who had made who'd done well
in in on the frontier of canada
essentially because it was in this town
called grand prairie which was pretty
new
a lot of them were immigrants because
alberta is an immigrant
a province it was only established in
1905 they'd all kind of
lifted themselves up by their bootstraps
and i'd also worked for guys like that
who owned like i worked in restaurants
from the time i was 13 until the time i
was about 17.
and i admired those guys even though i
didn't i didn't
agree with their politics but i admired
them and that bugged me it was like
jesus
hear that i don't agree with them
intellectually but i admire them and
then i'd go to the socialist
meetings and i knew some like committed
working-class hero socialist types
you know they were the real deal but a
lot of them were activists
and they just drove me crazy i didn't i
couldn't stand them they were whiny and
resentful and
they weren't admirable at all even
though hypothetically we shared
political view and so that really
put a knot in my tail and that was
another realization that well i just
didn't
i realized that i was like 16. mouthy
smart i could formulate an argument
um i could speak but i didn't know
anything
and thank god for that so i figured i'd
try to see if i could learn something
before i
dared to do anything political but
doesn't that speak to another quality
which is humility
which is something that frequently in a
lot of our young people they're
you know that are lacking as well that
ability to look in on oneself
and realize that they don't know the
answers the fact that you may have this
confidence you may be bright you may
have the ability to articulate
you may be able to win arguments you're
describing me
exactly well you know
it's not that easy to figure out that
just because
you win an argument you know if you win
an argument you think well i'm right
because i won the argument
i can tell you that's not going to go
very far in your marriage
so one of the things i learned in my
marriage
quite quickly was that sometimes and
it was the same on my wife's part
sometimes your best bet is to help your
partner make make the best argument they
can to defeat you
because just because you can win the
argument doesn't mean you're right
it really doesn't mean that it might be
that your partner has got
a handle on something they can't
articulate it very well
but but their intuitions their ability
to detect patterns is
is spot on and you can crush them
verbally let's say or
using other techniques at your disposal
whatever they might be
and you think well you know i proved my
point yeah
fair enough perhaps but if your wife
isn't on board well good luck for you
and just because you proved your point
doesn't mean the world is going to
accept that conclusion and
it that's that's also something i think
that we do a bad job of teaching
young people you know because we teach
them that
if you win the argument you're right
it's sort of the hallmark of being
intelligent
and fair enough it's better than losing
the argument but
but it's not as good as learning
something that's for sure
um john you we were circling around
the idea of socialism and communism uh
a little bit i wanted to ask you given
what you as a psychologist know about
human beings do you think
that there's something fundamentally
incompatible with
in that world view with humanity
or do you think quote unquote hasn't
been tried properly
oh well it hasn't been tried properly
means that the world hasn't been
fortunate enough
to have me run it that's that's the
constant claim well it hasn't been tried
properly what that means is well i
understand this system deeply and if
those if if i was in charge or people
like me then it would work
it's like no it wouldn't that's that's
what would happen is you'd be wiped out
by the next
batch that were even worse than you
that's what would happen
so it's such an arrogant claim that it
hasn't been tried properly
it's so but having said that
like it's not i understand the
motivation for
uh like the desire for an egalitarian
distribution of valuable resources and
we should walk through that
so it systems have a tendency marx
commented on this
but it's much deeper than marx's uh
realization
systems have a tendency to radically
distribute
resources unequally and that's really
destabilizing yep so and there's a
couple of reasons for that
one reason is um as you get
more you're offered more so i'm in a
position now where
i am offered an indefinite array of
opportunities
and i don't need them i'm not ungrateful
for it but
once you're saturated with opportunities
and your time is completely taken up
more opportunities can't be utilized and
so
and if you have money well it's way
easier to make more money i mean you can
lose it too
but it's way easier to make more money
once you've got started
and so once you are educated you have
some capital you have a connection
network
um and then let's say on in addition to
that you're well known
you can just multiply that endlessly and
but then on the other end of things if
you have nothing
well you can't even afford to get
started
yeah so like if you start a business the
most difficult customer to get is the
first one
once you have 10 getting a hundred is
not that hard
but getting from zero to one is
virtually impossible
and so zero is a really tough
it's a hole that's really hard to climb
out of and it's not good for society
to have a lot of people at zero
so there's this propensity for people to
fall off the end and to
degenerate down to zero and another
propensity for resources to aggregate in
the hands of very very small number of
people and it
look it doesn't matter what dimension
you measure that on so like if you look
up
among basketball players you look at
successful
you know number of points scored there's
a few people way out on the extreme
if you look at number of records sold
records produced
songs written popular songs written it's
like
five composers account for 95
of the classical repertoire but it's
only
five percent of the music they wrote
that's played
and so you see that happening in two
ways there
and the problem with that is that it
produces this radical inequality
in society and that's really
unsettling because you have a mechanism
that's very deeply embedded within you
that runs
as far as we can tell on serotonin a
fundamental brain chemical
and the the degree to which serotonin
regulates your negative emotion
is dependent on your status within the
group that you
strive for status within and what that
means is that
if you're on the bottom end of the
status hierarchy
you're much more prone to negative
emotion
and that actually hurts you physically
you'll die sooner
you'll age faster you'll develop all the
age-related diseases
faster it's a real calamity
psychologically and physically
and so there's endless motivation to to
to work against that tendency for
resources to be distributed so unequally
the problem is we don't know how to do
it
it's so power is such a powerful force
we don't know how to do it and
simultaneously
maintain creative and productive
endeavor for example
so because you want you want everything
to be more productive
right because you try to wipe out
absolute poverty
and maybe even give everyone you can a
certain amount of luxury
and maybe that's even better for the
planet because richer people tend to
take better care of the environment
so you want absolute wealth to rise and
you don't want inequality to
become too extreme but the systems that
have been set up to manage that
are not good at it they don't work and
marx he attributed inequality to
capitalism
that's wrong it's
seriously wrong so the diagnosis is
right well inequality is un
intolerable psychologically um
it or at least it's extremely costly but
that doesn't mean we know what to do
about it
jordan let me just jump in there very
quickly because this has always been
the problem for me when i look at like
free market right wing people i go you
expect everyone to pull themselves by
the bootstraps that's not going to
happen that's not
that a lot of them can't that's my point
right lots of them can't because we
understand people have different iqs and
different
genetic bases and different experiences
in childhood and whatever
and on the other hand you've got people
on the left who say well inequality
isn't tolerable and i agree with that
but as you say the systems that they
trying to apply
in order to address that don't work and
don't make any sense and create terrible
outcomes
so where is the golden middle well
that's
look the reason that i'm an advocate of
free speech
is that the golden middle moves and so
how do we find it
well we talk about it where is it it
moves all the time
yesterday's solution isn't going to work
today it it
so that that golden solution is a is
genuinely a mobile point because
inequality even changes with time
you know and and the conservative
viewpoint is inadequate i was watching
the crown
and the seasons with maggie thatcher you
know and thatcher
extraordinarily conscientious person
that's her fundamental
attribute and that is a predictor of
conservatism and that's dutifulness
industriousness orderliness
by the book patriotism all of that if
you want someone to run your company
you want a conscientious person if you
want a teacher you want a conscientious
teacher
it's not associated with artistic
creativity that's that
predicts liberalism that's openness in
any case mark maggie thatcher is
extremely conscientious and she believes
that
hard work will get you there and and
that should be
encouraged and and everyone can pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps
and
look there's truth in that if you look
at what predicts
people's success across time this is
where psychology is actually reliable
as a science we know some of what
predicts
life outcomes and we know it validly and
reliably
so the best predictor is iq and that
accounts for about
25 of the differences in outcome between
people
so a lot's left unexplained right 75 but
25 is a lot um the next best predictor
is conscientiousness
and it accounts for about five to nine
percent
which again isn't leaves a lot
unexplained but it's not nothing and
then the third one is
how sensitive you are to negative
emotion and it accounts for something
like three to four percent
um so it is definitely the case that if
you took two people
that are equal in some valuable domain
the one that works harder is going to
do better and that might even compound
over time
but if you take two people of radically
different iq and they both work equally
hard the person with the higher iq
is going to crush the person with with
the lower iq
and you know you said we know that and
and but we don't because
you can't even talk about iq in modern
society
it's such a hot topic and it's not
surprising
it's like i know the iq literature for a
variety of reasons partly because i
built tests to predict performance and
and studied that for 15 years
and my tests couldn't sell at least in
part because they actually worked and
were too threatening because of that
well and there's reasons for that but
if you're if you have an iq of under 82
you can't be inducted into the american
armed forces
and the reason for that is the armed
forces have done iq testing for a very
long time
and they're hungry for people always so
they're not going to throw away anybody
that they can
use they found that they couldn't teach
anybody with an iq of
under 82 anything that made them
valuable they were a net drain and
that's 10
of the population
so that's there's about as many people
with an iq of 82 or lower as there are
of people who are capable of doing well
in a
institute of higher education
so and among that population those who
work harder are going to do better
but but in a cognitively complex
environment
they're at a marked disadvantage and can
the conservatives can't deal with that
they don't know what to do about that
and fair enough you know it's like it's
a very hard problem and the liberals
they say
the liberals take the opposite tack
which is even more annoying in my
estimation it's like
well you can train anyone to do anything
and that's
that's so wrong that that it's
hard to even know where to begin i'd
love it if it was the case
i'll give you an example of this so the
americans
in their war on poverty ran a program
called head start
and head start was a program that
everyone wanted to succeed conservatives
and liberals alike and so
the idea was get disadvantaged kids
early
and enrich their education say between
the ages of three and five preschool
so the americans poured immense
monetary resources into this project and
and it has been studied in terms of
outcomes
for decades and
its goal was to increase cognitive
performance that was its goal
and it did but did but the differences
went away so the hope was if you got the
kids early and taught them
they'd get they'd develop an advantage
and then that advantage would compound
across time
and it would ameliorate the worst
effects of poverty and who wouldn't want
that right like
i don't care who you are everyone wants
that um
the kids did leap ahead academically but
all the other kids caught up by grade
three or four and then after that there
was no differences at all between the
head start kids and the non-head start
kids
except the head start kids were less
likely to get pregnant and drop out of
school
and they were more likely to graduate
but that looks like it was a
socialization effect
probably some of those kids were
shielded against the worst of their
family environment
by being in daycare but there was zero
effect on cognitive ability
very unfortunate right because because
that was that was a large scale
social experiment everyone had the
highest hopes for it
no effect on cognitive ability what
you're talking about jordan is actually
the great taboo in education
i i i was a teacher for many many years
and my my head with the head deputy head
would go to me in the primary school
why is it that you know this cohort
aren't doing as well as last year's
cohort
and it was seen as taboo to just go well
last year's cohort was smarter
yeah no one no one can tolerate iq
look it's the only thing psychologists
have ever discovered
really except for maybe the big five
it's
like these are facts say iq is
unbelievable it's easy to measure
to measure iq all you have to do is take
any
set of questions that require
abstraction to answer
and so you could take 20 questions
and you can do that you know better or
worse but with 20 random questions
you're going to get a decent estimate
so take 20 questions ask a hundred
people the answers
sum up the answers rank order the people
that'll be correlated with iq at
something like
0.8 0.9 really high really high
that's all you have to do and then
that'll be predicted with their life or
that'll predict their life outcomes like
economic
uh economic success for example
that'll account for about 25 of the
difference across people it's
unbelievably powerful and it's
unidimensional as well you know you hear
all these
appalling claims that there are multiple
kinds of intelligences and multiple
kinds of learning styles and skills and
look people people differ in their
abilities and they're not all reducible
to iq
but in the in the realm of intellectual
endeavor it's one factor it's one thing
one thing it's not decomposable not not
really
and that's harsh man it's harsh let me
ask this question jordan because i feel
like it's begging to be asked and
you've teased that you've put us in a
position where i have to ask you this
question
uh given the way that you've been
talking about this
and that question is i mean it comes
obviously
what is our fear of this conversation
there is i feel it i sense it as we talk
about this
there is some kind of pandora's box at
the end of this conversation
it um it violates our moral sensibility
you know we we deeply believe that human
beings are of equal value
it's a predicate of well i think it's
probably a predicate of human biology in
some sense but
maybe not but in any case because you
could make a case that we're
aristocratic by nature too but
forget about that certainly it's a
it's the fundamental axiom of the west
everyone's equal before the law we're
all of equal value in that transcendent
sense
okay well what does that mean
practically
well what we hope it means is that
we're sort of roughly equal in ability
or trainability at least
and we're not and no one that doesn't
sit well with us
we don't even know what to do with it
we're very uneasy with it and then it's
no wonder
now ignoring it isn't going to help and
also what also isn't going to help is
you know in boston for example recently
they shut down a lot of the gifted
programs because
the ethnic makeup of the classes was
un unacceptable it wasn't randomly
it wasn't randomly selected let's say or
or it wasn't
uh representative of the broader
community
and it's no wonder that that bothers
people who wouldn't that bother
but what are we going to do in that
situation you shut down the gifted
classes well
who are those gifted classes for are
they for the gifted kids
or are they for society at large
there isn't anything more valuable than
human intelligence
and if we don't utilize it well then we
let it go to waste
well how can that be in anyone's
interest it's a resource that we should
maximally exploit even for our own
narrow self-interest
but we can't and so gifted programs
they're always
people are never happy with them or even
with the idea
you know you can be as you can you can
celebrate differences in athletic
ability
and we certainly do we're very uneasy
when we celebrate differences in
intellectual ability
it's kind of a non-starter it isn't part
of the problem that we don't want to
admit that we all have our limits we
like to pretend that we can go out we
can achieve anything in fact
isn't that the basis of the american
dream but the reality is
we can't and that's not simply the world
that we live in
well this is a nice upbeat conversation
inspiring people all over the world
isn't it
well like like
working hard helps a lot
so hooray i mean there's one example for
example
in general the the offspring of first
generation asian immigrants to the us
outperform the offspring
of americans but also the the
the offspring of second generation
immigrants
why it looks like it's because they work
much harder and they work harder enough
to give them
what's roughly a 15 point iq advantage
equivalent and that's roughly the
difference between a college student
average college graduate say and the
average high school graduate
it's a big difference and it's a big
difference so
so work hard set your sights
you know 60 hour weeks discipline all of
that
no doubt and but you know there
there are pretty pronounced individual
differences in the ability to do that as
well
so even that's a rough
even your ability to focus and
concentrate in a disciplined way seems
to be
quite affected by underlying biological
factors
and that's also unjust it appears unjust
in a fundamental way
so it's tough and it's something that i
used to talk about many
from we used to go over this again and
again in the start from
all the time the question that
frequently came up
was in a world of automation you have
these people
who have got low iqs and before they
used to be able to go and do menial jobs
in a factory
and they used to be able to do that job
and work brings dignity
it's one thing it gives people a sense
of purpose what are we going to do
in a world of automation with these
people who have lower iqs when they
simply can't access
jobs well it looks like what we're going
to do is give them
phones i mean
we all have that problem in some sense
right it's like it's not like any of us
is occupied fully
by our jobs and so we have free time
spare time
time to waste you know i ask
undergraduates on a pretty regular basis
how much time they waste today and the
average is something like six to eight
hours a day which is a lot
well what do people do with that well
they're on their phones they're on their
computational devices and
now will that provide purpose and and
uh meaning and productivity um
who knows the technology so new and so
rapidly changing that
all you can say is well look it's really
absorbing
everyone's glued to it it's addictive
and it's just getting going you think
it's addictive now you wait till the ai
algorithms learn how to manipulate your
attention
by watching your eye movements because
that's coming down the pipeline so fast
that
well facebook owns oculus the vr company
and the vr headsets can read your eye
movements and
your eye movements are a direct pipeline
to your attention
and so in the ai systems are going to
figure that out real fast
so now does that deal with the
productivity issue
no probably not you know how it is in
the tech world unless you're on the
cutting edge
you can't monetize your your action
you know you guys have this relatively
new podcast that's a pretty
pretty new world you can monetize it
because you're on the cutting edge
you're on the leading edge
in five years people who start that's
going to be much harder for them
to do what you did they may have other
advantages
yeah well we wish we'd started when joe
rogan did
that would have been great for us as
well hey constantine
do you love trigonometry of course
incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire
plus my handsome jawline whatever takes
away from your hairline but if you do
love trigonometry and you want to
support us
there's only one place to do that and
that's on locals
yes locals is a brilliant platform that
has been incredibly supportive to our
show
and other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people
who love trigonometry that's right it's
a place for you to hang out with
like-minded people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in
join our community by hitting the link
in the description
and the pin comment below see you there
guys
john you bring up technology i was going
to move on but
let's talk about that a little bit i
think we've seen
the impact of this modern technology and
particularly social media
on the political landscape on the mental
health landscape on almost every area of
our life
what hey i got something horrible to say
about that well then
we've kept it upbeat so far jordan so
let's carry on down that path well i'll
let you guys see what you make of this
um about three years ago i was
interviewed by
uh the economist and we were talking
about aggression
and i said that men are
on average more aggressive than women or
they're more physically aggressive
so among children for example boys are
more likely to
kick hit bite and steal and that's not a
bad
operationalization of aggression let's
say and then if you look within boys
a small proportion of the boys are that
way at
two most of them get socialized out of
it but those that don't
are stably anti-social and criminal into
the adolescence and adulthood
and then that burns out around 27 28.
that's the developmental trajectory of
aggression doesn't look like it's
learned
okay so however there's something else
so that's interesting enough it's like
it's there at two it's a rage circuit
it's an old old biological circuit and
it gets controlled and most aggressive
kids are socialized by the time they're
four
and if they're not you can't socialize
them after that that's also
very interesting and rather
disheartening
but women girls however they are more
aggressive than
males if you measure aggressive
aggression
differently they use reputation
destruction
so well we've seen what happens with
social media
physical aggression doesn't translate to
social media
but reputation destruction
that translates to social media
unbelievably well
so maybe it's time to have a little chat
about toxic femininity
well there we go jordan i've got a
little piece of paper here with some of
the questions we were going to ask you
and the next one on my list is why do
people hate you
i think you've answered that why do you
think why do you think
well i was gonna ask you this what would
you point to
well let me ask you this because i think
this is an important part of it
uh helen lewis who's interviewed you and
who's who wrote a review of your book
who she hates me yeah she hates you
i've met helen lewis and she's
interviewed me and
of all the things you might say about
her you wouldn't say that she was stupid
and you wouldn't say that she was poorly
educated right
so i might say that
i was being jealous she took advantage
of the education that was offered to her
but yeah but but but education is so
corrupt that
mastering it makes you an expert at
nonsense
touche touche i like zabda but let's
just go with the she's intelligent point
so she should be able to understand your
arguments and i'm sure she does
and yet i noticed time after time where
an intelligent person even kathy newman
you wouldn't say that she's stupid
uh and lots of others come after you
with a vitriol
and a visceral you can feel it
you can when you want to be there yes
right well when i went to the gq
interview yeah
look i've got to say when i went to the
kathy newman interview
kathy newman was very professional we
met in the green room beforehand she was
perfectly polite um in a professional
sort of way you know but that's fair
enough
professional politeness beats the hell
out of you know random rudeness
so i'll take it um when i walked into
the gq interview and
this was i was already pretty worn out
at that point
um there was a photo shoot first and
then the interview
and that place was hostile right from
the moment i walked in and so i'm kind
of on edge in that interview because i
could feel that and it was like
um the stage was set long before i
walked into that so there wasn't even
professional politeness
it was you know people can freeze up a
room some people are really good at that
i think maybe it has to do with smell
you know i lived with someone once and
you could tell if they were upset when
you walked into the house you'd get kind
of an uneasy feeling and
the only explanation i have for that is
that it's related to smell at some
unconscious level
in any case the gq
interview atmosphere was unbelievably
tense
and i was sort of in there for 45
minutes before i started talking so i
was
you know i was already in the position
of a cat who hears dogs barking down the
street
so in any case
it still isn't obvious to me
what it is that causes such animosity
well let me posit a theory jordan
because this is what i really wanted to
ask you tweeted the other day when helen
lewis
published a review of your book you said
why do you hate me i've tried to be a
good man
and i replied saying i think you've
answered your own question
and my fear is and my question to you is
do you think that fundamentally you
mentioned toxic feminine
i don't like to get into this whole
gender thing in that way because
the whole gender war is a stupid thing
to me as far as i'm concerned but
i do think it's possible that we live in
a society where some people
those people that i'm talking about they
they hate they don't want strong men
they don't want
men to be better they want men to be
weaker
and they see you as an agent of change
who helps men to be better and they are
scared of that
well
if you've had bad experiences with men
and you know that's probably the
universal female experience
right because we all fall short of the
ideal
and of course that's deeply
disappointing to women just as women who
fall short of the ideal are deeply
disappointing to men
but let's say you've had less than ideal
relationships
perhaps with any man in your life um
it might make it very difficult for you
to distinguish between
authority and power right
because if authority is misused it looks
like power and misused power is tyranny
and so the best thing to do
in the case of misused power is to
reduce the power
and if authority and competence never
enter the issue never enter the
the question then you don't ever think
you're sacrificing something you're just
dampening down the possibility of
tyranny this is partly why i
i the oppressive patriarchy narrative is
so dis
distasteful to me it's like look fair
enough you know i mean
every hierarchical system has its
tyrannical aspect
and you might say well let's get rid of
hierarchies it's like no
sorry you can't even see without a
hierarchy
because you have to decide what you're
going to look at and
you privilege what you're looking at
over all the things you aren't looking
at and you produce a value hierarchy
instantly
there's no escape from that unless you
could equally attend to everything
all the time which you can't so you're
stuck with hierarchies
there's no escape from them that doesn't
mean they're universally benevolent
because they're not
and they get warped by power but just
because they get warped by power doesn't
mean that that's their essence
authority is their essence and that's
competence right
and but if you can't distinguish those
two
well then it's all out assault on
anything that looks like power
so and there's definitely there's a huge
element of that it's so unfortunate
because you see then that
boys get punished for their ambition
you know and because that looks like the
route to power i knew
i had friends who were so guilty about
their ambition
that well in one case it killed him
he committed suicide now he had his
problems you know but
one of them was that he was unbelievably
guilty
about being white about being an
oppressor about
about any human activity because he
associated that with the despoiling of
the planet
it's not like we don't hear that story
over and over and over
so but it's so punishing
jordan don't you think part of the
problem as well is the tribalism that we
have nowaday
and the narratives that we all speak and
that we all seem to ingest entirely
without thinking and these
you know they're propagated right the
way through
you know through the way we interact
with each other and so on and so forth
in our society that when someone stands
up and goes
hang on that's wrong i don't believe in
that for x y and z
reason all of a sudden you're getting
people to think to challenge themselves
and that's a real shock and people react
against that
really strongly yeah well there's
there's always taboos in societies right
and they move around and obviously i
violated some taboos
um what exactly they were isn't
particularly obvious um i think
i'm not a fan of the of
currently promoted social justice
theories of
identity and that's also partly why i'm
not
why people don't like me or some people
don't like me
but that's also a technical issue like
your identity
the there's a this i stood up against
this law in canada bill c-16 which
compelled people to use
pronouns that other people chose let's
say
under the unspecified threat
um and i thought to begin with
that that was mostly a free speech issue
it really bothered me that that
i would be compelled to utter
any uh pre-approved phraseology
and i didn't see any precedent for that
in
english language law english culture law
and it was actually rejected as a move
by the supreme court in the united
states and i believe in the 1940s
so i thought it was mostly a free speech
issue but i've come to think more
recently that there was more to it than
that there was more bothering me about
it than that
um there's a theory of identity in the
bill
and the theory of identity is basically
predicated on the idea that your
identity is
your choice and
it's as mutable as your choice and also
that your choice
is enforceable on others
and you might say well look um
if i want to be treated a certain way
then why can't people treat me that way
well
maybe they could but how much force can
you use
that's the real question should they be
required to do it
well then you might say well perhaps if
it was in your interest they could be
required to do it but i don't think the
identity theory that's at the bottom of
all this is in anyone's interest because
it's actually
inadequate um identity
identity is something practical
it's a game that you play with other
people you have to play it with other
people they
have to cooperate otherwise it's not
playable
and so if you're going to be successful
in the world and we know this from the
developmental literature
in relationship to child development
when you're two you're egocentric and
you tend to impose your game on the
world
and that means you can't play with
others and two-year-olds are notoriously
non-social they don't engage in
mutual play if you put two two-year-olds
side by side
they'll play but they won't play with
each other now what
what what um piaget the developmental
psychologist great developmental
psychologist noticed was that around
three or four
children will start to negotiate the
game so a two-year-old just be playing
with a truck back and forth
and maybe the other two-year-old is
playing with a doll and they're side by
side
but at three they have the doll or the
truck and then they decide whether
they're going to play with the doll or
the truck
and then they lay down the ground rules
for the game and then they both abide by
them
and so they have a little identity
within that game
but it's shared and that means that they
can cooperate
and compete within that game well that's
the beginnings of identity
and so your identity is is
a mode of being and perceiving that
opens the door for you in the social
world
it isn't only a tiny part of it is who
who you feel you are now it's not like
that's an unimportant part
but
if you feel you're an unplayable game
that doesn't help other people play with
you
and so part of the reason that that law
and all of the
philosophy let's say behind it ideology
more accurately
has this egocentric view of identity
and it's never made explicit and right
it's like
we use the word identity we won't even
talk about what it means
well it means and then we'll say well it
means
your felt sense of sexual identity let's
say or gender identity or
what however far that might be extended
fair enough but no wrong
that isn't how identity works it's way
too
sparse a theory to be
playable you know and i i insist on this
playability because
in in a marriage a marriage isn't one
interaction a marriage is one
interaction then another one then
another one then another one
and that pattern of interactions has to
be played in a way that doesn't
degenerate across
time right and there's an ethic that
governs that
and if the ethic produces a
deteriorating game then the relationship
will end
so the game you're playing has to be
repeatable
and it's out of that necessity for
repetition that ethics emerges
actually and your identity has to be a
playable game
that means it isn't something you can
merely enforce on other people
it doesn't work and so the people who
are
hypothetically being helped by this are
being encouraged to adopt a theory of
identity
which is counterproductively egocentric
and you say it's counterproductively
egocentric and i would agree with you
but do not think that the reason we have
been in
that we have adopted this ideology as
you say
is because it's a quasi religion and
that stems from the fact that
we don't have religion anymore in the
west you know we're
we're more and more living in secular
secular societies
well there's a chapter in my new book
beyond order called abandon ideology and
it
and then ideology and idol are kind of
the same thing i d o
l be careful what you worship i i i
think ideologies are crippled religions
so and i make a case for that in beyond
order and in my first book maps of
meaning
um a religious framework of complete
religious framework offers you a
balanced view of the world and
you might say well how do you know if
it's balanced it's like fair enough you
know and how do you know that your
viewpoint isn't just in other ideologies
these are good questions um i can give
you an example of two ideologies that
put together make a
a complete world view let's say um it's
sort of like
joining the philosopher hobbs and
rousseau at the hip
hobbs believed that you know the state
of nature was chaos and that every man
would be at every other man's throat
without the
benevolent uh influence of culture and
rousseau believed that human beings were
essentially good but
and that culture warped them and they're
both right
and you say well how can they be both
right when they say the opposite thing
and well
some things are the the thing they are
and they're opposite at the same time
unfortunately
so anyways consider the environmentalist
ideology
so it posits that nature is
benevolent and wonderful gaia the
interconnectedness of all things the
beauty of nature the
the uh the sustainability of the natural
world in the absence of human beings
it's a it presents a very positive view
of nature
and it presents a view of culture that's
like the raping savage
it's something like that that human
culture you see that in movies like uh
have those blue-haired those
blue-skinned aliens
oh i'll remember it there was a freudian
slip with blue hair
jordan that's another archetype isn't it
it's avatar
that's right so this this is the theme
of avatar and and so
there's this natural world and there's
the military industrial complex that
comes in and rapes mother nature and yes
there's the terrible
adversarial individual who's utilizing
the social structure to rape nature
and that's one story so
that's the environmental story in the
u.s there was another story that was
dominant for a long time that was the
frontier myth
and the frontier myth was well nature
was chaos and desolate and
and waste and the noble pioneer who was
positive would bring the civilizing
force of society and make nature
fruitful
and so you have on the frontier myth
side you have the positive individual
and on the environmental side you have
the negative individual and
on the frontier myth side you have
positive culture and the
environmentalist side you have negative
culture and
on the frontier side you have negative
nature and on the environmental side you
have positive nature
if you put those things together that's
the world of human experience and
ideologies
stories for that matter use those
characters but
unless they use all of them there's a
bias
and and the problem with the bias is
that something important isn't being
taken into account
so for example if you view the west as a
patriarchal tyranny it's like fair
enough man
like how you could you could
advance evidence for that forever
but well the lights are on and it's warm
you know so yeah the terrible tyrant but
but how about a little gratitude for the
benevolent king
the same goes for the natural world it's
like well of course it's beautiful and
it shouldn't be despoiled but
you know if someone dropped you naked in
the middle of the jungle that isn't
exactly how you'd be thinking about
nature
because it'll eat you in no time flat
and so it's
it's doing everything it can to destroy
you at every second
despite the fact that you're also
dependent on it for everything
and so it's a religious view in my
estimation takes all of those factors
into account it
it and then it says you've got to strike
the balance
between the tyrant and the benevolent
king between nature as a destructive
force and nature as a benevolent force
between the hero that's the individual
and the adversary which is everything
terrible about the individual
i was going to say when it comes and
i've thought about this a lot and i was
wondering what your
take on this is to me when you look at a
lot of religions
it's about the fact that man is
powerless before god
and the realization that you are weak
fragile mortal
and that you you need to worship god and
salvation lies in god
but the identity ideology focuses you
to focus in on yourself what is unique
and different about you
which ultimately breeds a sense of
narcissism and therefore a sense of
dissatisfaction
and hopelessness as well have you become
religious again
catholic school he sounds like he's
preaching right there
well i would say that there is that
element to religious belief but there's
also the
an element element in it generally
speaking that's enobling because
there is the the constant insistence in
christianity for example that
you do have the you know you are a
creature of god you are
assigned a divine worth that you have an
immortal soul
and you could be far more than you are
and so there's an ennobling there as
well
um so i think i think the religious
viewpoint is salutary in the way that
you described because it does attempt to
remind you that there's something
outside of you
i do think that the identity theory
that's characteristic of
um the woke movement let's say is
narcissistic to its core
technically speaking it seems very
egocentric and
it i had this sense when i was
surrounded by protesters
at the university of toronto for example
some of them were trans people who were
protesting me and
you know my sense was you think that
i'm your enemy but i see something wrong
with this that's going to hurt you
it's not good for anyone else but it's
also not going to help you because it
isn't right it isn't oriented property
isn't going to
it isn't going to produce the results
that you want
and so but it's it's it's taken me a
long time to put my finger on exactly
what it was that was bothering me there
might be more too but
certainly the identity theory is is
unbelievably sparse
and jordan do you think the the the
trans issue which you
you talk about which was sort of the the
start of this journey that you've been
on to some extent
and you know i remember francis and i
when we started trigonometry two and a
half years
ago you know we were saying should we
should we look into this should we talk
about this and we were like well this is
an issue that affects
at that time very few people you know
it's a it's a local issue for them it
doesn't really have any impact
and yet over the last two and a bit
years as we've educated ourselves on
some of the implications of this stuff
having had trans gender and transsexual
guests on the show and talked about all
of this
it seems to me like with this trancing
where
demands are now being made of us to
accept things
that are so patently not true
that is where a lot of people are now
starting to become
aware of this as a breaking point
because in and of itself it's not
necessarily as i say an issue that
affects a lot of people
but just that demand then you've talked
about it in the context of the soviet
union where people were required to
publicly declare things they knew were
not true as a method of demoralizing
them more than anything
it seems to me that we've almost got to
that point is that how you feel about it
well i think you know another part of
the reason that
the bill that i objected to bothered me
because was because i saw it as part and
parcel of a complete
ideology and so it was sort of at the
vanguard of that ideology and
i felt that once this had been
established that
increasingly unreasonable demands would
manifest themselves and
i think that's continuing to happen
what would i say about that
well i went over the identity issue
that's that's kind of where my thinking
has progressed to with regards to that
issue
you it it it it's
not solving the problem and at all
as far as i can tell and it's it's
it and i don't think that the i don't
think that it's been helpful to further
confuse young people about who they are
so for anyone you might have
straightened out and i don't see any
evidence for that yet
i think there's likely a hundred people
that have been left more confused
well this is the worry for me because i
i believe fundamentally in the pursuit
of truth and i believe that's important
and i believe that people who
who pretend to believe in things in
public that they know are not true are
harming society i fundamentally believe
that
but on the other hand i also want to
combine that pursuit of truth
with a compassion and and
respect and tolerance for people
who who feel that they are quote unquote
in the wrong body and whatever and i
i've been trying to square that circle
in my head
for years i'm trying i'm trying to
understand how one does that and i don't
i don't know that i have the answer
quite yet do you
no i wouldn't say so um
i just found a limit point for me the
limit point was i'm not going to say
words that ideologues want me to say i
don't care what the reason is
and i suppose part of the reason why
it's justifiable to hate me
i suppose is because that looks like
it's uncompassionate
you know what's the harm and i was asked
that a lot well what's the harm in going
you know these poor people are having
great difficulty
well i'd have to believe that movement
in this ideological direction was likely
to help them
you know before i would consider
compassion appropriate grounds
to go along with it i don't believe that
i think the the
whole the whole notion is so ill
conceived
i looked at all the background documents
that were associated with the law and
all that did was further my conviction
that there was something
deeply wrong about what was happening
and even it wasn't going to help the
people that it purported to help i
couldn't see any evidence for that it's
really hard to help people
you know it's really easy to make things
worse and there was certainly nothing
built into the law
to assess whether this change was
actually going to be beneficial it was
just the assumption well we know how to
reconstruct things so the world will be
better
it's like no you don't it's it's way
easier to make things worse than better
especially when you're messing around
with something
as fundamental as gender identity
you know which children usually have
reasonably well established by the time
they're three
you mess with that at your peril as far
as i'm concerned
so and then you know you've seen the
spread of
of gender transition surgery yeah um
we've covered it we've had someone from
the tavistock clinic on our show a
whistleblower from that
uh place where a lot of this stuff was
done uh
look it's it's an impossible circle to
square isn't it
i just i don't know we seem to be stuck
in this
loop uh and i don't know how it gets
resolved and i'm deeply troubled that
you
you know you say you haven't squared
that circle either i really am
well the problem of of how to fit in
is a permanently insoluble problem
you know we all sacrifice our pound of
flesh to adopt
a persona that makes us acceptable
socially
there's huge benefit in that no
we wouldn't be able to talk if we didn't
use the words that dead people uttered
we we were the beneficiaries of
socialization as well as the victims and
the victim element of that is permanent
there's no
and for some people it's much worse than
for other people because it's harder for
them to
match their temperament to the social
demand
but it's very seldom the case that
radical social transformation is the
answer
to that problem because those radical
social transformations tend to go
sideways in in unexpected ways
isn't part of the problem jordan that
we try and be compassionate with people
and
sometimes when you're compassionate and
i've seen it when i was a teacher where
teachers try to be compassionate and
actually
whilst trying to be compassionate you
end up making the easy choice
or the weak choice which in the long
term ends up damaging people
more well look
if you look at the way people's
personalities are structured
um you kind of have two exploratory
dimensions openness so that's creativity
maybe that's exploration of the realm of
ideas and extroversion and that's
social landscape exploration
and then you have three dimensions that
are more associated with
stability and um
those are negative emotion that's
neuroticism
agreeableness that's compassion and
conscientiousness and conscientiousness
and agreeableness are both social
virtues
and you might ask well why do you need
two social virtues why isn't
one enough compassion well the answer is
i think the answer is probably time
frame
so conscientiousness think of margaret
thatcher
conscientiousness is a cold virtue
it's like why do i have to take this
medicine
because it's good for you will you force
it down my throat
if necessary well won't that hurt my
feelings
yes but if you don't take it you'll die
and that's a conversation in some sense
that you have with sick children
you know and compassion compassion is
for infants
now that doesn't mean that and having
said that
let me make no mistake about the fact
that we're often reduced to the state of
infants
so if you're extremely ill and you need
to be taken
care of right in some sense you've been
reduced to the state of an infant
and that compassion is necessary for you
but conscientiousness
it says well this is hard but if you do
it
it'll be better next week or next month
or you can make these sacrifices now and
society will benefit as a consequence
you can forego
this gratification which is very
frustrating
and but the long-term consequences will
be better
and so compassion isn't enough and so if
you bring in conscientiousness virtue
which might be judgment for example or
justice which are both conscientiousness
virtues
then you're it's easy to seem
cold-hearted
and we were talking about squaring the
circle as well we don't know how because
mercy and justice often conflict
right but they're both necessary
principles
so why can't everybody just do what they
want to all the time well that's sort of
an agreeableness question that's a
compassionate question and the answer is
well it just
it doesn't work over the long run it it
degenerates and deteriorates
i mean i'll give you an example of the
conflict
um i remember one time my daughter
got ill she was about three and she got
this
mouth infection that was really quite
brutal she had a really hard time
swallowing for about two weeks
it was very painful and so we let
some of our rules relax like we let her
come into bed with us for example and
we let her be more dependent than we had
previously
and no wonder because she was suffering
dreadfully
but there was a huge price to be paid
for that when she got healthy again
because we had to go through the
training again
and we learned then well that we learned
that was an object lesson in the price
to be paid for excess compassion
in the final analysis it wasn't a
helpful move
and so and the problem with with with
agreeableness with compassion too is
that it announces itself so
self-evidently as a virtue
that if you if you wave a flag and say
well wait here's the limit case for that
it's almost impossible for you not to be
regarded as cold-blooded and
and and harsh you know and
women are more agreeable than men so
they're more compassionate
and more polite than men and
the probability that that's associated
with their
the necessity for them to be extremely
patient with
extremely dependent infants is
very very high but that doesn't mean
that it's the right principle to be used
to govern your relationship with adults
and i can't help but see
the spilling over of agreeableness into
the campuses for example
manifesting itself in claims like well
this is a home
this is a place where people should be
comfortable this is a place where people
should feel welcome
and everyone should be included and well
fair enough those are virtues but
it isn't obvious that they're the right
virtues for a university
or they're certainly and even if they
are they're certainly an incomplete
set of virtues what about beauty and
excellence
what about um discrimination the ability
to make value judgments
you know that just that word itself has
become a curse
in some sense to be discriminating well
that means you have judgment you can
tell the difference between what's good
and what isn't
and that means you have to admit that
some things aren't good and that's not
compassionate
and jordan and you've been uh out of the
game for a while we're so glad to see
you on good form
and doing well one of the things i
wanted to ask you is
kind of a lot happened in the time that
you were away i hold you slightly
responsible for that because things were
going all right and then you go away for
a year and a half and then things go
downhill
you must have obviously you've had a
terrible experience and i joke but
when you came back and you started
paying attention to the things that had
happened in the world
what was your first reaction when you
saw the
the blm protest the trump election
and all of that everything we've seen in
the last year or so
what was your first thing that you went
you looked at it and you went
oh
i don't know if i ca i don't know if i
can answer that
um i think i'm still probably trying to
wrap my
head around the current situation and i
that i don't have any
particularly trenchant observations on
how things have radically transformed
partly because the covid virus has
thrown such a loop into everything that
you know who who can who can make any
judgment about
the state of current affairs it's
impossible
with any luck the vaccines will work and
there's lots of them so perhaps we'll
beat the virus that would be
really good if we managed that that
would be a miracle
and then the world will limp back to
something approximating normal and
we'll see what that new normal is i
guess at the moment my judgment is sort
of suspended
plus you know the democrats took power
in the u.s and so
now the liberal end of the universe has
got control again and
that's going to have um a transformative
effect of one form or another but it's
impossible at the moment to see what
that is
especially with all the uncertainty
that's associated with the kovid
lockdown so i would say
i'm just sort of watching to see where
all of this goes
um uh because it's we're not in a normal
circumstance and so what what
conclusions can you draw from it who
knows what's going to happen in three
months
if we're fortunate everything will
reopen and we can go back about our
business with maybe a renewed
appreciation for just how bloody
remarkable
walking down a street with open shops
really was you know
i i hope we can remember that but until
then i'm just going to watch and see
and yeah i don't i don't i don't feel
i'm sort of watching with open-mouthed
amazement and and trying to
and trying to keep up as are we all
jordan
that the question your book strike a
chord
strike a chord with me because i see
them as a way especially
for a man as a guide to how to be
successful
as a as a way to make the most of your
life to develop your life to take
responsibility and all these kind of
things
and one of the things that i've seen
with men of my age i'm in my late 30s i
know i look younger you don't have to
say it but
but in my late 30s i see a lot of men
struggling
with what does it mean to be successful
when you when we look at that word
success what does that mean to you
and how would you inspire men of my age
and younger
another late feeling yeah it's too late
for me but to to
actually become a success
well first of all i think it's really
worth thinking about what success means
and i try to do that a lot in in both
the books
um it's really fun to make other people
successful
like that's this is one of the the
reasons capitalism i would say gets a
really bad rap
and an unfair rap like the people i've
known
who have been successful in the
capitalist
enterprise and a lot of them are
entrepreneurs um
rather than managers let's say just it's
just that's the population i've been
exposed to
and this was the same among the
professoriate for that matter
one of the great pleasures the people
that i've seen who i respect
took was in mentoring and so
don't underestimate the radical
satisfaction that's associated with
helping other people develop one of the
reasons that good professors
well and good businessmen love to be
in the position they're in is because
they can identify young people who are
promising and
open up doors of opportunity to them
it's really intrinsically motivating
and so you know when you think of
capitalism for example or success as
only a competitive enterprise that's a
real mistake because there's that aspect
of it that's
there everywhere in every enterprise
i've ever seen
so success real success means you're
successful in a way that makes other
people around you successful
you need both of those and that's also
really good for your conscience because
then you're not working at the expense
of anyone else
quite the contrary right you're you're
lifting the tie that lifts all boats
maybe you're simultaneously elevating
your own relative status but
it's really it's not um unreasonable to
put that in as a constraining
requirement
it has to help other people well it
helps you and i would say
the way we're wired now some people are
more selfish than others
but i would still say human beings are
unbelievably social and reciprocal
that's built into us at an incredibly
deep level
and it can go wrong and we can get
cynical and malevolent and bitter and
and work at counter purposes to it but
to be of service to your fellow
man your family members your broader
community
there are there are virtually no
pleasures that that compete with that
so and and and so that's partly why it
is useful to do a critique of
mere materialism and materialistic
satisfactions are pretty fleeting
they're not non-existent
but they're they don't have the deep and
lasting satisfaction of
well of successful mentoring for example
in the relationships that
build out of that so i think
i don't think there is any success at
all without moral success
in fact i think that success without
moral success is actually a form of
torture you know if you don't let's say
you don't feel you deserve anything um
because you're
you know that you're being you're not
being a good person and that's your own
judgment and
let's assume that you're accurate you're
not because some people will judge
themselves far too harshly but let's
just say you know
you have reasons to have your conscience
bothering you
and you're not successful well at least
you don't feel the
continual injustice of that you think
well i'm a son of a [ __ ] but i don't
have anything
but then let's say you're successful
well you know that's all you'll gotten
how can that do any and then maybe you
have to rationalize constantly to live
with it
everything you collect around you is
nothing but a
source of torment and a constant
reminder that you're
criminal in your fundamental orientation
that you've
ruined people on your mad scramble to
the top jesus you don't want that like
you seriously don't want that and no
amount of
relative material status is going to
even come
close to rectifying that you want
your conscience to be clean clear you
want your interpersonal relationships to
be
honest you want to be reliable and
dependable and if you can add exciting
and adventurous to that so much the
better
but success means to be successful means
to be
good and you say that successful means
to be good
isn't that a problem whereby where in
society particularly our society
where people judge success they judge it
on the requirement of property
material goods and possessions and
therefore there's
there's that imbalance where someone can
be morally good and a fantastic person
but
in a materialistic society seem to be a
failure because they haven't acquired a
great deal
well that that definitely is a problem
when you have productive people
that that's a problem in how the mon
it's a measurement problem in some sense
you know
economic success is generally associated
with intelligence and conscientiousness
so there is a rough
correlation between ability let's say
even moral ability and success
now i'm not making too much of that but
i do know
look if you're going to be a successful
businessman especially across
business person across multiple
dimensions
multiple enterprises you bloody well
better be honest
because it's going to catch up with you
man and the probability that you're
going to be a successful crook multiple
times is very very low
you can do that but you have to move
constantly
right so your reputation doesn't keep up
with you so
there is some association between
success and
moral virtue thank god but it's
it's it's a rough approximation and
there's plenty of exceptions
it's very hard for creative people to
monetize their productivity for example
so you have unrewarded virtue and that's
a flaw of the monetary system
means we haven't been able to and you
might say the same thing applies to such
things as
our inability to pay home makers
now why don't we pay homemakers well
it's because what they produce
isn't monetizable for 20 years
and our economic system isn't
sophisticated enough to figure out how
to pay people
for returns that are that
you know pushed off into the future that
doesn't make it right
but we don't know how to fix it
technically right
i mean if you're a venture capitalist
and you want to invest in something you
want a
ten-fold return on your investment
within a handful of years
you can't afford to invest over a
20-year period and so
that makes it really rough on homemakers
because we're not sophisticated enough
to monetize it
so it's a measurement problem but unless
you can figure out a better way of doing
it
you're stuck with what we've got do you
want to promote your business to an
intelligent audience who don't need to
know your pronouns to buy your product
here at trigonometry we have over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms
and we frequently get over 3 million
views a month
that's a lot of new customers for your
business we speak with some of the
biggest guests from the world of
politics
economics journalism arts and
entertainment
all of them have spent at least one
month in the gulag
so you don't have to and we'll match
your product to the perfect guest for
you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on
that way you know your advert has the
best possible chance
of getting to the right people or as we
call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk
and we'll make your nightmares come true
uh jordan i was gonna ask you as we we
head towards the end of the interview
we've
there's another issue we've been
circling around and you bring up uh
the the issue of stay at home mums
and i feel like this conversation by its
very nature has been quite male centric
and i said earlier i think the whole
gender wars thing
and men and women competing over who's
more victim who's more this is a bit
silly because men and women need to work
together and they need each other that's
how i feel
so they have more right of course
exactly so but but we do live in a
society where i think some people
don't see it that way and want to
disrupt that uh
what what do you think men and women
need to do
more of to co-exist peacefully if you
might
or or to build healthy relationships and
to work together
well the only the i mean i can only tell
you what i've
experienced one thing that
people aren't taught to do is to
negotiate
and so that's what we need to do look if
you're either going to have traditional
gender roles
where everybody shuts up and does what
their mother did or their father did
which works as long as society isn't
changing too quickly that actually works
quite
well and it's quite a relief to everyone
because how many bloody questions do you
want to ask yourself
you know like you just have no idea how
much certainty you actually want you
know if
if you take a three-year-old and you and
you stand them in front of their clothes
closet and there's
20 pairs of you know 20 outfits there
say it's not that pleasant for the child
to have to pick
if you throw three things on the bed and
say pick one they're pretty happy about
that because they get some choice but
it's constrained
and you know people say they want to be
free but that's just complete nonsense
because
you run into paralysis of will with an
infinite degree of freedom
you you want a certain amount of freedom
but not that much and you sort of want
it when you want it
in my room in my marriage and in my
relationship with my children in my
clinical practice
it's you have to negotiate
that's what men and women have to do and
so i i talk about that particularly in
chapter three of my new book which is
don't hide
things in the fog it's like well let's
talk about sex for example that's a good
one there's a stumbling block in a
relationship
let's talk about sex well that's hard
people don't do it they're uncut like
they'll have sex they'll engage in
sexual acts but they won't
represent them abstractly and discuss
them
you know so well
how often should we have sex
well how are you going to solve that
problem well first of all each person
has to admit
how often they'd like to have sex they
might be uncomfortable with that right
off the bat
they might not even know because they're
so uncomfortable about it they never
even
asked themselves and then you have to
ask yourself well
what will i do if i don't get that
and people don't like that question
either because it means while you're
going to get bitter and you're going to
get resentful and you're going to get
mopey and whiny and
you're going to justify having an affair
or at least looking elsewhere and
you don't want to admit that about
yourself so you won't have the damn
discussion
like as soon as you know that you're
flawed deeply
and if you're sexually frustrated you're
more likely to
s to stray well then you can be afraid
of yourself enough to overcome the fear
to have the conversation it's like look
uh woman if we don't make love
three times a week i'm so whiny and
immature that i'm going to go to strip
bars and that doesn't work out well for
our relationship
and you know and she might say well why
that why don't you grow the hell up and
you know i'm so overworked i have 50
hour a week work week because i'm a
lawyer and
i have three small kids and they're
clamoring for my attention
and my goddamn husband is such a
miserable wretch that he
threatens me with you know marital
disintegration if i don't pull out
another four hours a week to please him
it's like fair enough those are two good
arguments since who the hell wants to
have that discussion
but my sense is it's tyranny slavery or
negotiation
and i've walked couples through this
process many times
and i have some you know rules of thumb
i've got kind of a kick out of the
critical response to the book
and it's been sort of universally this
controversial man is very banal
it's like look guys get your insults
lined up here
yeah which one is it well
unless i've managed to elevate banality
to the level of controversy which
perhaps is the hallmark of a good
self-help book
in any case you know my observation of
couples has been that they have to spend
about 90 minutes a week
in practical discussions about about
their joint life
the kids the household economics their
plans for the future all of that
and they need to carve out two or three
times a week in a
relatively established relationship to
have a date
and chapter 11 is that in my book i know
it's chapter 10
plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance in your relationship
you know it's like you have once she has
wants
um negotiate negotiate about everything
who's going to set the table who's going
to do the dishes who is going to clean
the leaves out of the gutter
who does what and because you either
default to traditional sex rules
or you engage in a battle battle of
resentful stubbornness
or you negotiate and to negotiate you
have to look and see how little and
stupid you actually are
and you notice oh you know i'm actually
annoyed when i have to do the dishes
who wants to admit that it's like well
why well because i'm kind of macho and
that sort of woman's work maybe
i mean who knows what the reason is
maybe you're just lazy maybe your mother
used it as a punishment
um you've described both of us in one
sentence he's lazy i'm a bit matcher
it's hard to negotiate unless you know
how little you are
it's like really that matters to you
it's like yeah
and then i've noticed in my clinical
practice these little things
aren't little you know you have to clean
up the dishes three times a day for the
rest of your life
it's like five percent of your life
cleaning up the dishes
five percent of your waking life how
you're greeted at the door
you know all these tiny things that make
up day-to-day domesticity
defines the relationships between men
and women
that has to be negotiated and and to
negotiate you have to start out
little and demanding and and then listen
and you know my experience in my
marriage has been
with mutual good will and
the commitment to radical honesty
negotiation
succeeds it's hard
but it succeeds and that's been true
under even extremely trying
circumstances
and so i always look at the micro
situation it's like well i don't know
how to regulate
relationships between men and women in
the workplace
that's i don't even think an answer to a
question like that is possible
how do you treat your wife how do you
treat your daughter
or perhaps how do you treat your female
workers your your females that you work
with
you can you can you can address these
issues at that level and
that's where we have to start as far as
i can tell and
i think that's another reason why the
activist types don't like me it's like
i'm not much for social engineering
start local man
it's that's where the action is yeah and
look we've got a couple just questions
wrapping up my final question for you is
you've talked about your critics and the
social
activist types and all the rest of it
what do you think is the most legitimate
criticism that people make of you
talk too much probably that might be it
i mean i've been trying to stop doing
that when i'm interviewing people on my
youtube channel um
other legitimate criticisms well people
are quite skeptical of
you know this comes out quite often i've
had this problem
i took benzodiazepines sort of
it's a complicated story i had my
reasons i was very ill
when i first started to take them i had
terrible insomnia
and i started taking them and they were
prescribed i just kept taking them
and that ruined my life it destroyed my
life
and i still haven't recovered i've maybe
recovered 10
something like that it's absolutely
dreadful
i write self-help books it's like get
your act together before you
change the world you know that's my
advice so you know do i have my act
together well i certainly
appear to have made a mistake i mean
i've gone over it with fine tooth comb
i was genuinely distressed
beyond my capacity to tolerate when i
went to see the doctor i
as far as i could tell you know i was
basically sleepness sleepless for about
a three week period
you know maybe i had micro sleeps during
that time but the subjective experience
was
a 21 day long day i was freezing cold i
couldn't pile on enough blankets to stay
warm
i fainted every time i stood up
i was like completely frozen with terror
it was terrible i don't know what
happened
and i went to the doctor and he gave me
benzodiazepines and so
i took and sleeping pills i only used
the sleeping pills a couple of times
i used these benzodiazepines and two a
day and
that cured the insomnia and it was very
stressful period of my life
and much stress followed and
i just kept taking them i was paying
attention to other things i never gave
it a second thought
really well that turned out to be a
mistake and then the question is you
make a mistake like that and you think
what does that signify
you make a mistake does that mean that
you know you're
you're flawed to the core as a character
maybe that's certainly possible it's one
possible truth so
so how do i you know i was terrified
when i wrote this second book because i
thought well
first of all might be re met by a really
harsh reception because i've invalidated
my claims to any credibility with
with what's happened in my life
but that didn't happen people seemed to
be forgiving
remarkably and um
and then i guess i was protected in my
own defense i would say i was protected
against that sort of criticism to some
degree because i never pretended that
i was writing the rules only for other
people
i i think i believe that that's evident
in my
lectures and my writing is that
i'm talking to me too you know i'm in
the crowd of
reprehensible degenerates that need some
work
and so i mean if they weren't relevant
to me
well how could i even write about them
in any realistic sense
so i'm you know among the great unwashed
who are
clearly in need of a little bit of
cleaning up and polishing and so
and that seems to be how the public is
responding you know
i read my comments on youtube and i take
them seriously and
the reviews the public reviews i don't
take the critical reviews seriously
because they're
that ship is sailed you know
i could write the reviews before before
i see them i know what people are going
to say because that decision has already
been made and some collective decisions
already been made
so what i hope people can
listen to what i say and read what i
read and they can
try it out for themselves and if it
works great and if it doesn't
sorry you know
jordan as comedians we we faced some of
this the the critical reviews i remember
someone told me very early on he said
the story about a critic talking to an
artist and and the critic says would you
like to hear my opinion about your work
an artist says yes go ahead and the
critic says it's worthless anata says i
know but tell me anyway
i found that a useful approach you know
i also i know why there are critics
like things need to be criticized
because there's too many things
so you have to rank order them so you
know what to attend to
um and there's justifiable criticism i
suppose in non-just and unjustifiable
criticism
i think one of the things i have
detected you guys can tell me what you
think about this is
i note in my critics reviews of my work
the same contempt for the audience i'm
trying to communicate with that drives
the populism that the same elites cannot
understand
it's like because there's this snarky
undertone constantly
well he's delivered delivering
pseudo-intellectual
banalities to reprehensible you know to
to the to the reprehensible unsuccessful
it's like well that attitude is exactly
what makes you so well-liked
you know and i don't have that attitude
i'm thrilled
to see the people who come to see my
shows
and i don't
feel like i'm lecturing down i never do
that
you know i'm always lecturing at the
edge of my ability
and assuming that my audience will
follow along and
this is something i think this is
something that
i've always felt that the people who
have written about me
have missed the story really
they're not interested in why what i'm
doing has this broad impact
and the reason it has a broad impact is
because i'm it's helpful to people
and so that says something about what it
means to be helpful
and there's something really interesting
there but
there's something about that kind of
help that's viewed with contempt
and i think it is the contempt that
drives this
anti-elitism it's not
and that that stumps the left so badly
it's like well why do the right wingers
vote for trump
for example well it's because they don't
like you
they don't like you why because you hold
them in contempt
with all your talk of compassion it's
like well i feel sorry for them well
that's contempt
and on that note jordan thank you so
much for coming on the show
we really appreciate it uh well the last
question we always ask is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society
but we really should be
well you know we don't have much of a
view of
what we want to do
and this is a real issue it's like when
i was a kid in the 60s there was this
i read a lot of science fiction there's
this sort of technological utopia that
bennett
beckoned and everyone was caught up in
it post-war period
the better future well
we seem to exhausted that the power of
that in some fundamental way
where are we headed and why
in some positive manner we're really
stuck on that
no political party seems to be able to
formulate it and
and so what kind of world are we trying
to create and why
that's what we should be talking about i
couldn't agree with you more jordan
thank you so much for your time and
you've been very generous with it i
obviously advise everybody to get the
book beyond order
and uh next time you are in london which
i hope you are we wish you a continued
speedy recovery but when you are next in
london we would love to have you
here i would love to continue i love
london i love
great britain it was so wonderful
to visit there it was great such a great
country
and we look forward to seeing you back
here jordan all the very best to you and
thank you guys for watching and
listening at home
uh we will see you very soon with
another interview all of them go out 7pm
absolutely see you soon guys and take
care
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below